je t'aime papa je t'aime aussi gérer des
très courageuse
alors qu'est ce qui t'es arrivé jeune
fille on va à minneapolis
c'est un accident suis tombé du ceto
part c'est le cas pour nous tous n'est
ce pas papa et j'ai failli te rattraper
j'aimerais faire un scanner pour être
sûr qu'il n'y a pas de lésion interne va
s'occuper tout je vais attendre justice
et que tu remontes
ça fait des heures j'attends vous savez
si ça va être encore long quel est sont
en péril monroe et je ne vois aucune
perryman rond il ya eu qu'un seul
scanner ce matin à 9 heures se veut dire
quoi
elles sont pas ici c'est la liste de
tous les patients de la journée je n'ai
pas trouvé un seul monroe je veux juste
voir ma femme et ma fille vous avez des
images de l'intérieur des urgences
il n'y a pas de caméras dans les salles
de traitement elles sont sous la caméra
on peut pas les voir sur six chars il
n'ya pas un mais yang
vous avez examiner ma fille vous savez
sony sombre le seul élément que j'ai
c'est votre parole qu'elle était bien
ici vous croyez que je les attendais
tout cas c'est pourquoi j'aurais compris
les chapes de ma vie est belle
je sais jusqu'à un truc qui tient pas de
moi
je vous ai montré les photos ça peut
être n'importe qui on est aussi inquiet
pour elle que voulez vous bien l'hôpital
personne ne sera blessé ce mec est tard
et ça se voit
mais c'est tous les ans
ce que vous avez fait de ma famille
qu'est ce que vous avez peut-être aller
[Musique]